everything is science so there's not
anything that you can touch or see or do
that has nothing to do with science many
students can tell you that I get really
carried away sometimes I get so carried
away and so excited about what I'm
teaching and I think that that's
infectious for them as well and it makes
them really excited and want to learn I
tell them right away I'm like you will
struggle in this class and that's okay
like I struggled in class you know in
different classes along the way and
that's the only way that we're gonna
learn something science classes that I
taught probably my first 10 years
students were not very active at doing
science there was very little ability
for students to fail at any of the
activities we did so I had this
conception when I started teaching that
in 10 years I was gonna be a master
teacher it took me really up until this
year to recognize that perfection is a
myth what scientific concepts are we
looking at Milani friction what's
friction about that initial engagement
or really enjoyment of learning they're
not going to want to pursue science at
I hope that they look at the world in a
different way and see science alright
also guys gloves love the opportunities
of science come from the unexpected that
comes through which include non results
because the process of science is
fraught with running protocols and not
having them work but then having
interesting questions that arise from
that process it's not just about a
struggle problem it's about just like
struggling and like getting through and
learning through your actual struggle
right like persevering so I want them to
be able to like stand on their own two
feet and prove to somebody else whether
in school or in life like why something
is correct or why something makes sense
to them with a little more time to
explore other dimensions of physics I
can construct these units in these
projects that are more authentic and so
they see what they could do if they were
to pursue an engineering career or
pursue something in computer science as
opposed to just pure applied physics
regardless of whether we've been
teaching five ten twenty years there's
always some other way that we can grow
and develop something else that we can
learn and potentially share with our
students